hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a girl's fabric face now
this is made by the same developer that
made sweet seven seven six well and this
was actually made before that developer
made sweet seven seven six and if you
don't remember sweet seven seven six
this is a little snippet of what so
weeds seven seven six is all about now
that we got that out of the way we can
go into this game with arms wide open
and we can know that there are probably
going to be multiple endings to this
game and it's going to be an interesting
experience
Stanislaw Joukowsky don't forget to play
alone and use headphones specifically
alone
it must be played alone there's a count
alone if you guys watching may be
flashing lights epilepsy warning aim is
extremely high in suspense I'll be the
judge of that and will cause scares I'll
be the judge of that by continuing you
are playing at your own risk such as you
space Crouch important and why would
Crouch be important and why is crowd
space now whatever that's fine look like
the record oh so let's make at least I'm
certain four minutes best of luck enjoy
the ride oh it's like a roller coaster
hi hello why oh I see okay I'm gonna
start again make sense what are we
starting again exactly and why are we
starting it ooh we're in a spooky house
paranormal findings oh hell yeah I'm a
paranormal investigator baby I'm a
determine if there's any ghosts in this
house
uh hell yeah well there's a key there
alright okay uh should I that seems like
oh I thought it was a ghost bad I
thought I found a ghost bed oh so this
isn't a ghost lamp for a ghost camera
that's just camera where I can place it
oh I hate that hi
yes yes sure okay all right
hello any ghosts in here anyone that
cares to jump on ooh what is this random
letters I doubt that very much
it's probably I can't open oh okay
really recording that definitely not
random letters why am I locked in here
who I'm not okay all right
well I've definitely hate that
definitely found some paranormal crap
going on here okay
doors are all kinds of paranormal so
someone smiling and chilling out on a
tree hey you stay open if I open you
that'd be great stop that up I don't
want to look
oh that's crouched space is crouched for
some reason all right locked okay good
great good stuff well one floor down
once I get explore the bottom floor I'll
I'll get out of here send the footage
off to my editor and Bob's your uncle
I'm gone what the hell are you riding
there Poseidon what that's not okay
locked let's get footage of that I hope
it makes a compilation of the footage
I've recorded at the end of this
that'd be a fun jump Cuddy adventure did
you guys know there was a time in my
channel and I didn't like to make jump
cuts you know edit anything
what am i charging and how am i charging
it just stepping into it with my hips
and it's drawing electricity from my
groin okay battery's full
oh it's charging my battery oh I stuck
it into my groin and it charged me okay
that makes more sense then whatever I
said interest oh here we go the reporter
asked when I told him my daughter went
off from home on Friday at 8 p.m. June
2nd that is the last time I saw her
after that everything just became dark
for me there was no point in living I've
lost my only reason to move on alright
well you know I'm not gonna make fun of
that at all because that would be rude
so what exactly am I looking for should
I take a nap in the ghost bed what is
that it's a my suitcase it's radio there
wasn't a noise in there before wait
where is that coming from
where's that coming from
okay whatever not important I guess okay
so it's shot of that
yeah it's great good stuff good stuff
boo hello okay there's a key there okay
that's either that to the padlock or to
one of these other side doors grab the
key all right
wasn't this one this one was already
open maybe it's the padlock hey how long
were you there
okay good thing I got that camera up
there what's in that hallway wouldn't
want anyone sneaking from me okay oh do
I have an image oh I do
Vera beat up key has something written
on it bottom gathering that's what I am
to set my two cameras and rest area
where does my other camera go is the
question they're doing down here you
know ooh well squeaky ooh Kim okay got
that I'm all set up and good to go baby
oh there's no need I should look around
the house for a bit to get a feel for
the area
oh I've felt the area all it needs to be
felt I felt it up and down make sure
nothing is different from the last time
I was here when was I last here what are
you talking about what I had things to
be different it's something don't let
her out
who does that me that did that ever was
that something else
oh are you photo piece you say all right
no I imagine there's gonna be a lot of
secrets in the nooks and or crannies of
this place so I should probably look in
all the nooks and or crannies just like
in the other game there's stop doing the
squeaky door thing I don't know why it's
still getting me sure sure sure
all right does everything look the same
ish yeah kind of I guess hello how are
you I asked you first
okay so that's a little odd but not too
different than the last time I'm here I
guess grab the handle one Oh what I grab
a handle 204 a contraption seeing the
sandal makes me realise there's no
secret of this place maybe yeah yeah
definitely
doesn't give me any burning yearning
feelings to run away as fast as I can I
need to charge my battery else I'm gonna
get caught with my pants down
what's with all our the noises what's
his happen what did I write how did I
write with this when I'm started how did
I how did we do that man it takes a long
time to church um I'm starting to get a
little dizzy I should rest it what do
you mean a little dizzy
Oh is there a gas leak which in case
don't rest I don't know all right cool
nap ski it is nap town baby lay my head
of rest Oh jana rama well I'm a
paranormal investigator so I then why
did you ask good talk buddy
good talk oh I am selecting cameras well
am i just doing this from an iPad while
I'm in bed
that's very relatable lightning there's
nothing to strange about that
along what which door was that is
something supposed to be wakey time for
the daily rush why am i sleeping in here
if I'm not even gonna win the house
that's always the that's always the
trick you got to sleep in the house who
would sleep in just an open hallway
who'd do that investigate change if any
who'd do that just unprotected no door
between you and a demon don't you didn't
you watch that one video error v
whatever the whatever the video was what
freak sleeps with their door open oh
[ __ ]
oh that's different oh that's different
I got a Kerber oh maybe 45 what's maybe
45 this is maybe 45 I don't know if
that's true but now that I have these I
can definitely go in the basement and I
can go down any stairs E which is like
my favorite thing to do Oh probably
nothing best not to check why would I
check why would anybody check no one's
you check I'd be silly note Oh their
face is so red I covered them with
cloths but the blood dry now the cloth
remains could this be for the better
guide me pure sacrifice will provide
considerable fortune for those of the
afterlife for young and your own will
grant such fortune upon the passing
acceptance of death is needed regret
hate sorrow will bring forth a loop okay
sounds perfectly reasonable let's bring
forth the loop baby
let's bring forth the loop
[Music]
so you and here what was that uh you
know what maybe maybe I shouldn't that
shouldn't open that up
maybe I should maybe I won't you know
maybe I won't excuse this grope nice
tunnel shot oh hey oh wait got that all
right cool
I'm just gonna pretend like there's
nothing behind me definitely anyway just
go back the way I came
why would you do anything like that you
don't want to and I don't want you to so
why would you so you won't is the answer
I think this uh this has got to be to
like the numbers and letter the letters
upstairs II my bladder why thank you
was it you that I was cuddling with last
night thought it was awfully snuggly in
this hallway
oh that there before I probably I just
didn't notice that anyway just gonna
place the ladder and doing doing doing
going up I go take valve Oh what it's
too tight what is say is too tight am i
crying I was crying it's on too tight
got a Kroeber who's crying who's being a
little bit of a [ __ ] baby what is it
what's going on here rap note Oh what
the hell was that always there at the
expense of others one can obtain it all
a true passing a true death a true
eternity nurture the four then select
them off
one by one start with the youngest then
proceed onward only the devil will hear
their suffering but you all will see it
in the end only the dead will know your
tale
acceptance is futile well these are
great notes very inspirational very
motivational to get me to do whatever
the hell you want me to do oh wow I
didn't catch that behind you ah ah I see
behind me behind you
oh hey bud okay
he's yo one to go he see you want go
won't go hard on them Wow
there has to be something in this house
that can loosen this valve up time to
rest time to rest now really now is the
time to rest he see you won't go does
that mean he see won't go I don't you
see you won't go I don't know Wow stop
who the hell hey let me charge my
battery in peace oh the fry didn't even
see the fridge burger this for the
insurance agents and everything anything
else you want to throw at me in the
meantime
no all right cool good good to know I'll
see you around kid see around lay my
hand arrest
I remember when you first came here 40
years ago when you were still such a
young girl sixteen or seventeen if I
remember you'd come by quite often to
set up and stay the night with the
spirits
you were very brave and in the end I
took you once I felt the drugs have
taken full effect let her out okay
wasn't that bear on the other side of
the hallway not crazy I mean yeah but am
I crazy ghost I got you I got you I see
you interesting right what happened what
happened
paranormal findings 5% hey I finally got
one a paranormal finding I missed that
first one it was too quick a little too
silly Oh gotcha Oh paranormal finding Oh
got you oh no okay interesting
interesting interesting okay I got a lot
of paranormal finding about that one a
lot of paranormal goings-on interesting
interesting very interesting I am a
whopping 13.9% of paranormal okay cool
good good great oh and I'm getting up
think that's not fascinating well better
go check that out
all right oh that's strange oh that's
not paranormal really that's a very
paranoid
[Music]
huh I doll so I have a bolt-cutter maybe
I'm gonna use this to get the valve
unless I don't actually need to get the
valve and I just need to snip the valve
hey who knocked that over all right so
what logically what I need bolt-cutters
for logically speaking what would I need
it for not what it seems
Oh interesting fascinating it's not
paranormal though therefore it does not
interest me so if that's not what it
seems
then what do I need to do to make it
what it seems
charge up real quick I say real quick
but I mean real slow oh I can cut the
maybe the lock off that thing I could
probably cut the lock off that thing I'm
Fred pretty strong with the thing cut
the rock love the rock right off that
cockeyed snip oh oh that's I hate it
here I go filming everything I don't
want to I don't why I'd rather not go
with this doors open I mean I could have
gone down here at any time or if there's
anything else in the hole I know I'm
just avoiding going into the basement oh
look listen I just want to go in the
hole very normal
alright whatever fine I'll get out of
here or I'm going in all helpful when a
month time so it's some day I don't know
what it is the house blood and then the
clock and then the month okay there the
house is crying or it's pointing to two
windows clock is 8 0 so 2 8 0 2 nope
okay umm I am unsure what that is if
that's referring I don't know the day is
the
thing it's gotta be another clue down
here or something like that not that I
want to go down here
oh yeah it's a maze great good ooh high
notes wait a minute oh no no no that's a
funny
that's a funny goof that's a little
weird
oh hey I hate it but I love it that's
good
spook that's a good one oh you sassy sue
oh I'm three dangling there with
importance to her side once lost all is
lost one use what is found to unlock new
meaning a picture of oneself viewed by
oneself dead placed in the room of
capture will alter all perception a view
of your body
lifeless has a power that is priceless
great good awesome okay maybe a power
box it's got no door handle oh well that
paranormal
so the under basement
oh it's the same weird door from before
oh oh I got you
yeah this seems safe yeah I definitely
want to go down here oh god I hate it
what is this why does there need to be a
sub-basement hello it's nothing but an
illusion once you leave and come back
you will see what once was after that
once you hear the music sound as I lie
in wait my door will open to seize your
fate Thanks
that's great thank you okay
oh I got some of that got some of that
all right cut you ghost we lie in wick
oh maybe I should bring this whole house
down then good thing there's a weird
charging kitchen what is
what is that the original USB like USB
0.1 a big brick of an ass all right
oh good good thing there's these
generators attached the lights and
nothing generating them in coffins we
shake well stop shaking the conference
what if we told you about shaking the
coffins oh you know you get what you
asked for
ooh with fabric covering our face okay
all right cool I don't like this place I
don't like this place I don't like this
place
I don't like it go back down
wait I don't need to tell me twice I'm
going back down you got it buddy oh my
god oh no are you gonna shake in your
coffins open up here to shake your legs
well I went back down you know what I'm
not too happy not happy about it not
happy at all did I get everything I
needed to open this door no okay when
day I don't know what day it is I could
try to brute force that but I'm not
gonna there's got to be like a calendar
or hey I need to talk with you I think
that got kicked aside what are you doing
here oh that's that's a little odd oh
yeah okay that's not weird I guess wow
this is definitely gonna hit the big
screen people are gonna love this people
are gonna love this okay good great
good great good anything else hey mister
what's happening
why why would you do that you don't need
to do that that's not paranormal enough
apparently Oh No the fan oh that's
that's sad all right Oh was that oh wait
I need the valve for that that's what I
need the valve for I'm taking this and
nobody can stop me valve did up what
just happened I heard something that
sounded a lot like a key drop down but
why would that cause a key to unless it
fell down below because why oh that's
the key because I loosened up the pipe
that it was connected to ready for
anything
ready Freddy Freddy ready great well I
think there's only one locked door at
the front door got to get out of here
time to go oh that's that's that's not
good
that's not good
oh well there's nothing in there so yeah
yeah that's okay this is bad maybe 60 is
that scary enough what do you mean 60 61
60 para norms the unit of measuring
paranormal man I probably missed some
picture pieces here you have one gotten
too many there are some one has
willingly come young and beautiful
appears to be recording a video I placed
a pill in her water she should suffer
hallucinations and weakness her name is
Ana she's very warm I hate you I hate
that and I hate you you are horrifying
okay so there's some kind of a door here
all right cool good oh yeah I think it's
time to get out of hell ha
there's too much hey I've read this one
before hey that sounds familiar
okay there's something going under the
bed Oh going down under the bed oh why
oh my baby the way I think it's time oh
it's gone I think it's time for another
nap is what I'm thinking I'm thinking a
few more nights in this place clear my
mood right up ooh yeah that's a crying
baby why are we crying from what we
doing what are we doing
Oh Oh that that's that oh oh
adios I guess I can't am i hallucinating
I need to find an exit Oh No
looks like I don't have one all the
windows seem to be boarded up let's go
down to the basement down okay I don't
know what Danis three I am NOT Anna I
hope you know maybe I am but you don't
get to call me by that I'm not running I
don't even have the ability to run so
you just suck ass just a big suck ass is
what you are oh oh that Daddy good
that's that's not good that's not
paranormal really dad ain't paranormal
it's not paranormal enough for you oh I
got you that's some paranormal juice
okay so who's thumping up here who's
paying off bumpy lumpy who's something
maybe old naps keel help me out
eat arrest I could I must be
hallucinating I should go rest for a bit
yeah yeah that's that yeah let's do that
yeah guys take a nap take a nap
perfectly same thing to do perfectly
good Loomis and plain as your mind was
feeling more and more
the summations to the point where you
became if you could just stop talking
that'd be appreciated every word you say
it's creeps me out on you've died the
others don't know too since you were the
final dog to perish oh I got no charge
oh hi I can't I can't
well that it's apparently not paranormal
enough all the teddy bear got pushed
over are you coming to where I'm
sleeping is that what you're doing
please don't do that
why did I have to take a nap whoa
got that on camera Oh
can't go back to camera one apparently
camera one is unacceptable yes I'm stuck
here there is something I saw them well
didn't need to look at whatever that was
anyway okay got some of that got some of
that action
I got Scylla now I'm awake apparently
and not dead don't know how it was a
twisted game all four of you died uh-huh
but I did place the doll on your passive
body to never forget you man that makes
it all worth it that makes it so much
better my dude my dude why didn't you
say that from the get-go you made a doll
by our dead bodies of course that makes
us all good that makes us goochy goochy
I mean please I'm not an animal of
course of course I forgive you
was that the front door open down there
I do not trust that Oh doll on one left
okay Yeah right what's the message of
the day it's your turn now okay my turn
of course I would hope so it's about
time to be honest to be fair I don't
trust that at all no trust that screw
that that's that's a trick it's a trick
you're tricking me I know what I'm being
tricked in it now exactly now it's the
time you're tricking me well I shall not
fall for it you tricky dicky you I'm
going down here now
thunk I just don't trust it okay I still
don't know what day it is you know
there's another safe at the beginning I
wonder if there was a there's a place to
get the code for that I don't know
probably nothing good for me down here
yeah whole lot of nothing nothing left
in the boxes
okay I'm gonna I'll play your game you
row good I'll go out the door free dumb
Oh hell's loop or deception maybe
interesting
hell's loop or deception maybe I don't
know is this gonna lead back into the
house
oh no oh
oh the desire to see me feeling okay Oh
[Music]
your resistance is what's causing this
my time to accept but I'm doing this for
all of you for all of you to know
perfect eternity this is not just for me
but for you too oh so I'm supposed to
thank you I'm supposed to thank you for
this is that was that what I'm picking
up from this ordeal I'm this this is my
thank you for this is my thank-you loop
and I think that's not good Oh didn't
like that thank you
[Music]
can't thank you enough
Oh what's happening oh okay got this
glass oh of course I grabbed the doll
that's what I was here for all along
great thank you
don't mind if I do
oh that's not very normal been afraid of
my own life there's so many times
uh-huh there's so many times okay what
you want it to end - why don't you think
about the rest of us and then this
dabbling and all the others well you
know kind of hard when I'm stuck in your
loop but thank you thank you so much
appreciate it big a you were just a doll
get it no glad no this is worth
recording press one to forgive press two
not I will not forgive you no screw you
you killed us yeah I knew what I'm doing
well I know oh oh oh no wait oh uh do I
take a nap now
oh no oh oh I won't forgive you
you were bastard not gonna thank you for
this you're gonna thank me you're about
to thank me so hard oh not there okay so
there must be some other secret to get
those open that I'm not aware of yeah
the power box is gone so there was like
another puzzle that I wasn't solving
probably from pieces that you would get
out of this the the safes weird hi I'm
recording
hey that's what you said at the
beginning of this it's all ooh it's a
Hello loop June 22nd 1968 June 22nd 1968
four girls and a man were found dead in
an old abandoned home located in
Sullivan the four girls in the age group
between 2 and 16 were found dead
scattered throughout the house with
fabric covering their wounded bodies
stuck with horrific amounts of blood all
girls are believed to have died from
severe blood loss while the man has died
from suicide with gun to head from being
changed in a cold crawl space locked in
a vault hung from the ceiling with a
hook and cut to death in a cradle the
scene was the most brutal the town has
ever seen to this we announced this the
murder as the girls with the fabric face
that seems like an odd name and I don't
know if you need to name it like that
that's weird
okay I'm getting it yeah that's what
happened at the beginning it's a loom
it's a loop your loop is a loop buddy
Lou I got the stubborn ending the bad
ending really the bad ending because I
didn't forgive ah you know what you know
what you go eat them eat an egg I don't
forgive you I'm not talking to the game
developer by the way I'm talking to
whoever that guy was but now I know the
day and there must be a way to get the
safe open from the get-go be a coup as
that must mean there's a way using the
day to get what I need but I'm not gonna
go into a blunt I may I may look up a
guide but I will get that true ending of
this I will I'll do it screw it I'll do
it
Friday 8:00 p.m. June 2nd
does that mean the code if the daughter
the furqan I'm gonna Friday 8:00 p.m.
June seconds 5 8 6 2 would be that or
it's probably 5 no nope no he is I don't
know
delicious juicy Paranormal Activity I
didn't know that noises were considered
essential Paranormal Activity to country
oh that's not paranormal really nothing
weird going on they're perfectly fine
feel like that very much should have
been something paranormal happening oh
yeah oh there we go that's what I'm
talking about didn't see that last time
it didn't even notice that was that why
are you breathing in there weirdoes
that's what I said it ghosts yeah you
weirdos you get out of here you freaks
gotcha baby that's a lot of paranormal
activity going on oh yeah it's just time
to soak all this up oh really that's all
that's my fill
that's my fill of that particular brand
of paranormal really nothing nothing
else to glean from that sheet moving
across the wind how can I move oh wait
wait wait now I'm getting more what from
what am I still getting some I can't
tell the achievements in the way great
good
got it got that yeah even that counts
just a little bit of a clangy clang oh
yeah record the darkness I say and
record the darkness that'll do it
alright so this should be June no Friday
8:00 o'clock June 2nd 5 8 6 Oh got it
okay cool good to know good to know got
that easy peas me really that notes not
paranormal at all oh I guess that
suggests syv been here before
it's a loop-de-loop that's what it is
Oh daddy didn't get enough of that I
can't believe it's it's it's happened to
me again I didn't think that I would be
enticed to go through
the game like I did sweet sound six six
again like to get to the good ending but
I want to know like it's it is pretty
intriguing you know what I mean got you
guy yet guy looking right at yes what I
thought yeah that's what I thought
that's what I thought okay whoa spooky
spooky aha okay so I had to look this up
there is a key back here and maybe 60 is
that's scary enough ah
so you only get that if you've gotten
over 60% of your paranormal findings and
with that I think this is the last piece
oh there's one more do I not have all
the pieces oh there's one more okay
alright but I do have this thing for the
power which is interesting
Wow nailed it power does that connect to
the thing up thing up in that room why
do you say I'm running ah aha Oh what
the hell he told me I was next next for
what to die huh that's not true dreadful
nope nothing
not even a little paranormal I'm
hallucinating
um okay swallow pill don't forget to
take one pill per day will keep you
healthy you know I don't know if I don't
know this is a good idea to take that I
don't think that's a good idea I don't
want to take that I don't want to take
that that seems like a bad thing I
should go rest for a bit yeah that's
what I should do
yeah it's definitely what I should do
here we go I'm gonna rest rest my weary
bones actually wait there's one more
thing I think I missed there was
something else that appeared like down
here or yeah because I discovered these
are all open that's right yeah yeah yeah
maybe it's um
Oh is there yeah the red one that's what
it was got it yeah yeah
yeah okay eighty-nine point nine six
percent I don't know if I need maximum
spewpa JH to be able to get to the
correct ending but whatever I don't know
nap time
what'll I see on the cameras gotcha
only a little bit yeah gotcha OH
103 baby 103 103 baby get out the way
achievement I got 103 Oh 100 I guess
it's 100 now oh now it's a hundred and
six very brood ah goddamnit come on let
me get the more oh you suck can't even
switch cameras sure that would have been
spooky to see but I didn't get it okay
so I got a hundred percent paranormal I
think that's good oh this is not just
for me but for YouTube we come together
just you whoa it's a window why is it a
window why don't I need a window where's
this go Oh who did that scare you
absolutely it did gooey interesting
interesting interesting interesting
interesting okay so I've got a picture
of a window that's good so apparently
now what I need to do is I do yeah I
forgot about that I probably would have
guessed this anyway but what I need to
do is I need to not forgive them
how about no I think this time I do I'm
pretty sure I do look I'm gonna get out
there's there's gonna be a window you
know that's what I'm looking for
it's gonna be a window you know that
window though that window okay maybe I
don't know oh it didn't game over oh oh
opus bulbous head missed my bump is all
this my OB where am I what's happening
this ain't paranormal what I did I break
Oh No
[Music]
the perfect ending to your journey yeah
it's perfect
okay don't feel perfect so we meet again
okay all right okay who you who you God
didn't lead this Aidan I don't know Who
am I supposed to address here all right
the loop has been successfully escaped
though it is unknown whether all the
others made it out to over 40 years of
bath since the loop was begun your
grudge has enabled you to get this far
all is safe now
no more herb will be discovered only a
passing of one so deserving well the
reward was that I got to die which is I
guess fair um the true ending there we
go so yeah I didn't expect to be playing
through it again but you know I kind of
just had to as a thing like it is really
interesting this game and the way this
developer makes these games is kind of
similar but you know it's still very
good I like that you definitely spooked
me the first time through more of like a
you know a haunted house team that you
know where everything is but after the
second time around but still still good
so shout out to Stanislaw Krakowski for
making that shout out to all of you for
watching it you want to see sweet seven
six six or seven subjects or whatever it
was I'll put a link to in the
description that's the other game made
by this person
it is also surprisingly scary so thanks
again let me know what you thought down
the comments below if you want to see
more scary games there also in the
description or in this petition videos
over there cut that [ __ ] out but thanks
again for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]